The Joe Rogan experience. That's
what, that's what I'm saying,
I have shit going on. I can't worry
overtly all day long about like,
is this meal going to, it's like, how
am I going to get fucked that shit?
But that's one of the things that
people like about it. Like, okay,
I'm on this diet now I've
got to concentrate. Is it
like meal prep? Really? Um,
yeah. Or meal prepping and
Sunday prepping all up.
Where I look at my shows
at [inaudible] prep,
I am in control of my world
asteroid hurdling towards us.
Complete control of controlling rocket
space. I have a finite lifespan.
I have to constantly feet
and shit. Everything's fine.
Everything else is okay.
Yeah, everything's fine. My buddy texted
me today by the way, I want, he goes, uh,
he had a concern I talked about on
another podcast about how he couldn't,
he didn't shit for like five days.
Oh.
I have a buddy who went through that and
he went to the doctor and he has this
thing and he had to get help
for it. He texted me, he goes,
I just want to let you know I'm back
from vacation. I feel really good. Also,
I'm shitting like normal again.
And I was like, I feel like a,
like a really proud friend. Like
he, he was really struggling.
He was nervous about it. He was like,
dude, I haven't shit in like four days.
I was like four fucking days. Who was a
guy that I worked with on fear factor.
I don't want to shame him, so I won't
say his name. He wants it out there.
Great Guy. Um, he had a real
problem, a real problem.
It was packed in there for days and days.
It wasn't coming out and he could feel it.
Like you could touch his butt hole
and feel it inside. It was hard.
Fuck as hard girls.
Yeah.
So fiber dog had to go to a doctor and
they literally had to chip it out of his
asshole. Shut the fuck up.
Allocated impacted on his butt hole.
They had to get in there and break it up
and then they had to make him take this
like really intense laxative.
So he takes this really intense laxative,
like,
like weapons grade lacks and they're in,
they're chipping away at the stone wall,
which is essentially just like a dam to
keep all this shit juice is piling up.
Damn it.
Because he's got the impacted dried out
shit that should have been out of his
body days ago.
And then he's got the
fresh shit on top of that.
And on top of that he's got this
chemical laxative that just selling off
explosions inside of them.
And the doctor says it was a fucking
hammer hammer and a screwdriver just
whacking at the ship rock that's at
the bottom of his ass hole and then it
breaks loose and just explodes everywhere.
Fuck.
Like he gave birth to a dead seal,
just blah flying out of the bag.
All right, we got it. We got it.
How much did you, how much
weight you lose? I don't know.
But he said it was awful.
It was awful. Like they had a
PR pry the shit out of his ass.
I'm going to break it up.
Those are the kinds of pains those
downstairs today from you're not shitting.
Yes, it's a, what's it called? A, um,
you give yourself, um, imagine that.
What's it called? Come on, look it up.
You know what I'm talking about? It's no,
but there's a, there's a word it's
called [inaudible]. It's like a toxic,
like toxic shock syndrome that women get
if they leave like a tampon into long.
Yeah. If you're, if you don't shit
for a certain amount of time, you,
you poison yourself. Hmm. Yeah.
It starts to leak into your
organs and should something,
it's something absurdly just, there
was a show a one of those like, um, oh,
a 600 pound life or whatever those shows
are, this woman wouldn't shit. And she,
she, which she can polling in holding
out and they're like, purpose. Yes. Why?
Because she didn't want, she couldn't
move to shit. She was so fucking big,
she couldn't move to shit.
So the ship packed up and sat
around and they were like,
you're gonna fucking die. It's gonna get
in your bloods. It's going to get your,
your other organs in your bloodstream
and kill you. Isn't it? Like,
doesn't that freak you out when you watch
a show like that where someone's like,
like uh, uh, what are those called?
Hoarders like order or someone who's
gaining a ton away or things get there,
but you know that you could get there.
Yep. You know, you couldn't get there,
but you know that a person could
get there. Yeah, right. Right.
You now Andrew Santino May, 2019
you're not going to get there. No,
probably not.
You're fine.
But some people will get that bad road
and they can't turn around. They're stuck.
Yeah. And Age. But they compile it. Right?
Cause that cause the depression feeds the
hunger feeds the depression. Yeah. Yeah.
What does that,
that's shit.
[inaudible] he died after
feces filled bowel burst.
Oh look how much shippers there is rectum
a dilated up to 18 centimeters inside
his body and was filled with feces
according to the BMJ case report.
24 24 he's a child.
24.
This isn't some 80 year old man who just
is like, wow, he's autistic. Right? Okay.
It's probably constipation. Oh, okay.
Wow. Great. Now we feel bad. Jamie.
Thanks Jamie.
Fox baiting us with some shit.
[inaudible] still look at that
guy almost died from constipation.
So it's a few people.
Every year they had to surgically remove
two leaders of poop up coca cola bottle
filled with poop to leaders to lead it.
Think of a liter bottle of coke.
You take two of those fill with sand
and stuffed up your ass shit and you're
filled with sand leading to a
lack of blood flow to the leg.
He was pressing on his
artery, bro. Oh my God.
It was his shit was choking his leg out.
That's what was happening.
Shit was just Chinwag arm Shin Hospital
for 23 days and it took 13 days for you
could walk again.
Oh boy.
No explanation has been found yet as to
explain his significant faecal loading,
unloading constipation, looking
at these spell fecal, f, a, e,
c a.L is that because they're in
Australia? Probably fucking those idiots.
They guy was probably bang and Kangaroos
or something. They caught some disease.
No Chinese. Those people got no
time to pope. I'm faecal loading,
cycle us with the name.
Have you heard of that? Um,
coupled that they ate a raw rat heart
from Mongolia and they got the black
plague. What? Yeah, they died
exhibit the black plague from plugin.
Fucking crazy people around liver.
That's what it was. A liver.
They ate a raw rat liver and
they died of the bubonic plague.
Why did they eat it? Tigger bubonic
plague. I think it'd be bionic players.
Black sounds like, yeah, it's gotta
be Blue Bond. They have a bionic play.
What's the difference? Cause the
bubonic plague was a bacteria, right?
Well what's the black plague? That was
a virus, right? It wasn't that a virus.
What do you at Doctor? Not,
not anymore. I got this bar.
Apparently you're not gonna like keep the,
you can't keep the faecal loading samples.
College.
What did you think you were going
to be a comedian? Really? Man,
you're like this is a waste of time.
No, it's just funny because I'll show,
I had my, my mom throwing show, Andrew
Santina no case on his phone. Yeah.
Fuck that shit is one of those gangs.
The black plague was a aid,
an event during a time period,
and the 13 hundreds and the bubonic
plague is a thing you can get. Right.
But the black peg leg was
what? A viral diseases. It's
killing people, right? Yeah.
So it's the bubonic plague that these
folks got and they got it from eating a
raw rats, heart or liver. Think
it's liver. Can you get us,
what does this kidney, Kidney, oh, that's
in high school. Why would they kidneys.